e
[Musique]
je vous racontais l'histoire de la femme
de ma vie l'amour de ma vie
aïcha nous sommes au maroc en 1918
aïcha vient de naître à casablanca
c'est la fille d'un riche commerçant de
la bourgeoisie de fès elle habite dans
une grande maison avec un patio
peut-être que vous avez déjà été dans un
riad
vous savez ces maisons avec une fontaine
au milieu de l'eau qui coule des enfants
qui jouent un orangé qui exhale ses
parfums aïcha est une petite fille vive
intelligente presque effronté elle a
envie d'aller à l'école elle a envie
d'apprendre à lire et à écrire mais qui
lui a mis des idées aussi bizarres dans
la tête
malheureusement elle est en avance sur
son temps le patriarcat a encore de
beaux jours devant lui
comme toutes les petites filles elle va
se marier et avant cela elle doit
apprendre son futur job être une
cuisinière hors pair une maman une
épouse sans surprise
aïcha et marié un juge un homme de la
bourgeoisie de fès aussi bien sûr
quelques mois après le mariage il lui
avoue qu'il a épousée sur la pression de
sa famille qui a voulu le détourner de
son amoureuse car elle était noir
quand on est un homme blanc de bonne
famille on ne peut pas aimer une femme
noire il dit à et shakil apprécié car
qui n'apprécient pas cette femme qui
n'apprécient pas saboter ses grands yeux
bleus son intelligence ses talents de
conteuse
ils l'apprécient mais ils ne l'aiment
pas ils ne l'aiment pas meurtri blessé
l'appel rentrer chez elle chez ses
parents dépourvue du petit centimètre de
fine peau qui fait toute la différence
très vite son frère lui dit je t'ai
trouvé un mari
c'est un sous traitant un homme très
pieux qui suit une voie soufie plus âgé
qu'elle encore tout à son amour tout à
sa blessure encore dans l'espoir que son
amoureux viennent la chercher elle
refuse hélas son frère lui dit si tu ne
veux pas l'épouser tu devras trouver un
endroit où allez vous rendez compte
à cette époque pour une jeune fille ou
une jeune femme
la russe et la voie directe vers la
déchéance
alors la mort dans l'âme elle et elle
accepte d'être déplacé de casablanca
qu'elle adore à fès qu'elle déteste et
la voilà marier avec un homme dans le
coeur et un autre à ses côtés
le temps passe et achats à des enfants
et puis vient le moment où ce ou la
première de ses filles est en âge
d'aller à l'école
ma mère elle va voir son mari et lui dit
je vais inscrire notre fille à l'école
il la regarde l'air interloqué mais où
as tu été chercher cette idée bizarre
c'est une fille
il refuse ma grand mère insiste essor
larmes suprême si tu refuses je divorce
ma fille va étudier avec et sans son
consentement bentir a dit ce cas là par
chance mon grand père m
ma grand mère il accepte pour une année
alors année après année aïcha obtient
moyennant parfois la menace que sa fille
que leur fille ait à l'école vous voyez
le modèle pour aïcha c'est les mille et
une nuits
c'est à dire que c'est une femme active
stratège qui se retroussent les manches
jour après jour et nuit après nuit
le modèle c'est pas la belle au bois
dormant qui attend la solution
grâce à cette femme exceptionnelle ma
mère obtient son bac et va même faire
des études supérieures en france
elle choisit son mari et puis peu de
temps après un 22 juillet voilà que je
suis n'est à paris la classe non
enfant on me demandait de rien faire on
me demandait pas de faire à manger de
faire mon lit de participer aux tâches
ménagères
la seule chose qu'on me demandait
c'était de travailler et de bien
travailler travail ma vie tel était le
commandement c'est ce que j'ai fait ça
marchait bien
j'avais la chance d'être dans un
environnement libéral est ouvert dans
une société marocaine conservatrice
quand j'ai eu 13 ans mon père m'a
proposé d'aller en angleterre on séjour
linguistique
wow c'était extraordinaire aucune de mes
copines n'avais jamais fait ça
prendre l'avion casablanca londres
rejoindre un groupe de jeunes français
est passé trois semaines à londres
incroyable mon père a dû faire face à
l'hostilité de certaines personnes qui
lui ont dit mais c'est une fille elle
est jeune et londres c'est dangereux
une fille n'est pas sensé voyager seules
elle ferait mieux de passer les vacances
d'été à apprendre son futur job
mon père les a regardés en disant c'est
ma fille je veux comme ma fille
apprennent l'anglais
je veux que mes filles s'ouvre à
l'international je ne veux pas que nous
filles subissent les limitations de leur
mère et de leur grand mère
je ne veux pas que nos filles et un cap2
cuisine ménage
j'avais de la chance
j'avais un père féministe mon amie
myriam elle n'avait pas cette chance dès
son plus jeune âge elle était promise
et lorsque le samedi après midi avec mon
groupe d'amis quand on voulait aller
faire du vélo au bord de la mer on
allait la chercher et souvent elles nous
disaient non je ne peux pas venir avec
vous je dois rester avec ma mère nous
sommes en train de faire la cuisine
j'apprends à faire les cornes de gazelle
le pain le tajine
à 18 ans elle a été mariée à son corps
défendant avec un homme dont elle ne
voulait pas moi à 18 ans j'ai quitté ma
province
bye bye casablanca au revoir le maroc au
revoir le pays des droits des hommes
bonjour le pays des droits de l'homme
j'étais euphorique à moins la liberté
l'autonomie
vive la france après l'euphorie
c'était le début des premières fois
alors c'est parce que vous pensez
la première fois que j'ai voulu me faire
à manger
je me suis dit je vais faire un truc
simple parce que en fait je ne savais
rien faire donc je vais faire du lait
chaud alors j'habitais dans une studette
16 mètres carrés avec une petite
kitchenette et des plaques électriques
vous savez ces grandes plaques ces
grosses plaques électriques qui mettent
un temps fou à chauffer donc je mets le
lait dans la casserole
j'allume la black et je vais prendre une
douche une longue douche
même un truc aussi simple que du lait
j'avais réussi à le rater mais j'ai
gagné au grattage trois heures moi qui
n'avais jamais fait de man et de ménage
et bien j'ai été servi ça n'allait pas
être facile côté pratique
peut-être que c'est mon amie myriam qui
avait raison parce que elle au moins
elle risquait pas de mourir de faim pour
me consoler de ce ménage de cette de
cette corvée
j'ai allumé les infos
et là j'entends qu'une femme a été
battue par son mari
c'est pas possible non je sais pas en
france ça ne se passe pas au pays des
droits de l'homme au pays de la
déclaration du citoyen pour moi c'était
le choc
le grand choc alors je fais des
recherches et j'ai trouvé des
statistiques allemand cela je voudrais
vous montrer une image c'est la une du
journal libération de du 23 mars 2018
les filles sont le diable donc c'est en
france alors les statistiques en france
l'écart salarial entre les hommes et les
femmes est de 29%
c'est à dire que à travailler et gagnent
une femme coûte moins cher ou rapporte
plus c'est comme vous voulez une femme
sur trois subit un harcèlement ou des
propos déplacés des gestes déplacés dans
le milieu du travail
moi même trois patrons m'ont trouvé à
leur goût
8 femmes sur 10 vont subir des gestes
déplacés dans le métro fin dans les
transports ou dans la rue 225 mille
femmes chaque année vont être maltraités
physiquement ou sexuellement et enfin le
pompon tous les trois jours une femme
meurt sous les coups de son conjoint
pourquoi les relations entre les hommes
et les femmes ne sont elles pas
pacifiques ou même paradisiaque
depuis des millénaires la culture
véhicule que le principe masculin est
supérieur au principe féminin et par
glissement que l'homme est supérieur à
la femme
alors qu'est ce que c'est le principe
masculin le principe féminin
le principe féminin
c'est tout d'abord la relation c'est le
plus important c'est le ressenti
l'ouverture l'âme la bienveillance
l'intérieur le précieux le principe
masculin c'est l'action les résultats
l'expression la parole les faits la
raison l'extérieur nous avons tous en
nous les deux polarités aucune n'est
supérieure ou inférieure à l'autre elles
sont complémentaires
dire que privilégier le principe
masculin
c'est terrible pour les hommes pour les
enfants pour la terre et c'est encore
plus terrible pour les femmes parce
qu'elles sont put parce que nous nous en
python de la partie la plus importante
de nous
privilégiez le principe masculin
c'est comme essayer de se tenir
sur une seule jambe alors qu'on en a 2
ou essayer d'applaudir d'une seule main
tenet essayé avec moi j'ai pas l'air
débile a alors comment faire comment
faire je pourrais vous donner de
nombreuses pistes
je pourrais vous dire que nous devons
veiller à l'équilibré entre le masculin
et le féminin ni trop de l'un ni trop de
l'autre je pourrais vous dire que les
maires doivent arrêter d'investir leurs
fonctions deux mamans comme un lieu de
pouvoir et de regarder leur fils avec ce
regard énamouré et complaisant qui fait
qu' ils se sentent au dessus de tout et
devient parfois un petit caïd je
pourrais dire au papa de prendre leur
place de jouer leur rôle de tiers
séparateur et de ne pas laisser toute la
place aux maires je pourrais vous dire
que nous avons un exemple chez les
indiens d'amérique de prise en compte du
féminin de la relation de l'autre
lorsque les indiens d'amérique prennent
une décision
il s'interroge sur son impact sur cette
génération je pourrais vous dire que
nous avons dans le règne animal
un exemple de cohabitation paradisiaque
vous savez ce que les dauphins passent
leurs journées à faire ils jouent
ensemble et ils font l'amour toute la
journée
je pourrais vous dire tout cela et tout
cela est exact mais la réalité c'est que
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas et
personne ne sait vraiment nous savons
que nous sommes à la fin d'une époque et
au début d'une autre mais nous ne savons
pas comment rejoindre ce jardin d'éden
personnes à l'adresse dans son gps
dans cette quête d'une vie meilleure il
ya trois personnes qui m'inspire ma
grand mère qui avait cette vision d'un
équilibre entre le féminin et le
masculin de petites filles et deux
petits garçons qui marchaient main dans
la main et qui avait les mêmes
privilèges
la deuxième personne c'est kennedy en
1960 de kennedy dit nous choisissons
d'aller sur la lune
nous choisissons de de défier les lois
de la gravité
et malgré les sarcasmes et malgré les
sceptiques
sept ans après un homme à poser le pied
sur la lune et à défier les lois de la
gravité
enfin martin luther king qui en 1963
fait ce fameux discours vous souvenez à
avoudrey date one day j'ai le rêve qu'un
jour mes quatre enfants ne soient pas
jugés selon la couleur de leur peau
mais selon leur caractère moi aussi j'ai
un rêve un rêve fou
elle rêve d'idéalistes un rêve de
révolutionnaire j'ai le rêve que dans le
domaine des relations hommes femmes
sur la lune qu on défie les lois de la
gravité
j'ai le rêve que les petites filles
comme les petits garçons soient jugés
non pas par leur genre mais par leur
humanité et mais pour leurs différences
célébré pour qui ils sont garçon ou
fille est comme ma grand mère j'ai le
rêve qu'il n'y ait plus de hiérarchie
entre les hommes et les femmes que nous
soyons tous égaux que nous soyons tous
aimé respecté sous toutes les latitudes
et pour nous aujourd'hui j'ai le rêve
qu'enfin on puisse marcher sur nos deux
jambes et applaudir de nos demain merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]